today we reached a historic milestone in
our war against the coronavirus over 1
million Americans have now been tested
more than any other country by far not
even close and tested accurately and I
think what I'd like to do is ask
secretary a czar who's done a fantastic
job to come up and just say a few words
about the fact that we reached
substantially now more than 1 million
tests please thank you Alex
well thank you mr. president for your
leadership in marshalling all the
resources that we have for this
unprecedented testing effort and thank
you mr. vice president for leading a
whole of economy approach to testing as
the president mentioned today the United
States hit more than 1 million samples
tested a number that no other country
has reached we're now testing nearly
100,000 samples a day also a level that
no other country has reached I want to
thank every partner that has been
involved in this effort that includes
all of the men and women of the FDA and
the CDC including director Redfield and
Commissioner Han together the FDA and
CDC have work to balance the need for
testing on an aggressive scale with the
scientific rigor that Americans expect
working with our testing coordinator
Admiral zero ah they have now truly
unleashed the ingenuity of the private
sector and our state and local leaders
the centerpieces of America's historic
approach it's a testing I want to thank
those state and local leaders who have
used their on-the-ground resources and
knowledge to lead testing and make it
much more easily accessible to the
Americans who need it I'm also grateful
to FEMA with whom we are now working
closely to get state and local partners
what they need I also want to thank CMS
where administrator Verma has given
health care providers unprecedented
flexibility to scale up capacity for
testing and treatment that has ensured
that tests will be paid for finally we
would not be where we are today without
the many American companies
entrepreneurs and scientists who have
worked
day and night to develop as of today 20
different emergency testing options with
the FDA responding to requests for
authorization tip typically within 24
hours the number of options is growing
nearly every day
FDA has also opened up new options for
using the available tests like self
swabbing and new options for reagents I
also want to thank FDA and other
components of HHS for incredibly rapid
action on other tools that we need this
weekend we actually work to secure 30
million tablets from Sandoz and 1
million tablets from Bayer of
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine which
are potential kovat 19 treatments and we
authorized Battelle's new decamp
decontamination machines which can each
sterilize thousands of essential and 95
maps for reuse every day so thank you
mr. president for your leadership and
thank you to everybody who's played a
part in getting us where we are today